let's move on real quick to stranger
things which is the number one
thing people on twitter ask me to ask
you it's i can't imagine what your
twitter looks like when it comes to
stranger things
so i'm going to put you on the spot
because i've heard two things
and i would like you to confirm or deny
um
i've heard that filming has finally
wrapped on season four
and you guys are coming out in the
spring of next year
on netflix blink if that's true
[Laughter]
this is me trying not to blink right
exactly
all literally um i mean i have been
along with
the brothers uh we have been kind of tag
teaming and directing it
uh as recently as now um
so uh not quite done filming um
imminently and all i can say about
release
is by the time this airs
uh we'll at least have given the world a
ballpark
and i'm not allowed to say more by the
time free guy comes out
august 13 um part of that answer will be
no
got it so you're saying that maybe
there's another trailer coming that will
announce the release date
it's not a full trailer i can tell you
that but maybe it's a little taste of
something
no i i completely get it look it's it's
tough because the audience demand
for information is huge because it's a
long gap since the last season
it's it's an unholy gap and
i want to say what i can say and speak
freely on this as much as it pains our
viewers
that it will have been so long trust me
it pains matt
ross and i more it is a
kind of perfect storm combination of
covet shutdown slower pace of filming
in covet protocols and health protocols
which are necessary
and coincidentally
we chose season four to be by far
and i mean by far far far the most
ambitious of the seasons
it's already known that we in fact i
think that we put on the internet
right as the pandemic was starting i was
over in lithuania with david harbour
shooting that piece that revealed hopper
is alive so you kind of know
we've got some action in hawkins we got
some actions apparently in russia
we have an entire storyline set
elsewhere
that will soon come to light and so this
is the first season
where we have this sprawling geography
multiple location shoots
and we're doing it all against a
backdrop of
a world that has made filming slower
longer and delayed
so that's why it's taking so long um i
i don't know if you've announced this or
said it and i in an interview i did with
you guys at comic-con you and the
duffers
i want to say you guys said it would be
five seasons
is it still five seasons are you allowed
to say
is it or what i mean do you have the end
in sight
uh yes i have the end in sight the
brothers have the end in sight
um there is a plan and
that too will be shared not quite as
soon as
a sense of when season four is coming
out um but
soon enough i can say this no one's
making it up as we go along
and there is an end game if you will
last question on stranger things it's so
popular for netflix
um i'm assuming they've begged you guys
for spin-offs
or anything else that can take place in
that universe um
have you guys had those conversations
and is it something that
is percolating um
there's been you know begging us for is
is i wouldn't characterize it that way
steve i'd say
what's been made clear is this is a
there this is obviously a tent pole
arguably the tenth pole franchise in the
history of netflix
obviously certain other shows played key
roles in their evolution but stranger
things with 196
you know viewers over the time that
we've been on the air
uh you know that's a lot of household
196 million
and it's unique in that netflix service
what's been made clear is there is a
an interest and a real voracious
appetite for any offshoot
any other iteration format
or extension of the franchise the
characters
the mythology uh and certainly
those conversations are hardly evolved
but they're also not
non-existent boy did i dance around that
one
but anyway and you cannot take those
words and turn it into a headline that's
like
stranger things executive rooster sean
levy confirmed spin-off
because i didn't do that no no no no i
listen i know exactly what's going on
which is
i mean i know it there's meetings of how
can we continue this without ruining it
what are organic ideas that that fit
you know is it something that we can do
and
the reason stranger things take so long
is everything
is handmade by a very small group of us
and i think we spoke about that
at comic-con steve like the brothers
they want to direct a certain number out
so every year
i have to direct my episodes every year
we
have to be in the edit room and lay
hands on all of it
ourselves so there's no if you look at
this show there's no
like 12 executive producers it's still a
very small group
and the controls are rigorous on each
episode and on
anything that the franchise does whether
it's the drive-through experience in la
or you know or a nike sneaker that was
put out in the summer of
2019 we see and have to approve it all
or a pinball machine well those are
extra extra collectors edition
fancy and rare